[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes de la tnt tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité
dans ce journal la colère à la pompe
vous l'avez sans doute remarqué le prix
du carburant ne cesse d'augmenter la
chaîne du nord oui où est allé prendre
la température auprès des automobilistes
visiblement excédé les abus sexuels dans
l'église une victime sorte de son
silence vous entendrez le témoignage
poignant d'un homme victime d'un prêtre
pédophile un témoignage recueilli dans
la loire par nos confrères de ts et puis
non selon elle une actualité un peu plus
heureuse avec des carnets roses au zoo
on vous emmènera en haute-garonne faire
la connaissance des sept croquignolet
lionceaux né au zoo de
plaisance-du-touch bien heureuse
nouvelle pour le parc qui n'avait pas eu
de naissance de lionceaux depuis 2013 et
puis en fin de journal vous verrez que
toutes les sorcières n'ont pas attendu
le 31 octobre et la soirée d'halloween
pour sortir de chez elle elle s'était
tout donné rendez-vous à rodemack en
moselle nous y étions pour vous
faire le plein de sa voiture fait mal au
portefeuille
les prix à la pompe n'ont jamais été
aussi élevé depuis près de dix ans dans
les stations-service la colère gronde
comme ont pu le constater caroline
fichten et jérôme ouvrons de wéo la
chaîne de la voix du nord
cet automobiliste a fait le tour des
ponts pour essayer de trouver le
meilleur prix comme beaucoup le coût de
l'essence impacte assez lourdement son
budget albeau courait pas mieux je
travaille sur saint-omer
c'était une nécessité de trouver une
essence moins chère ça fait cher la fin
du mois prêt pour aller travailler quoi
50 km par jour allez donc 105 km aller
retour sur un mois ça fait 300 320 euros
on fait des moitiés de plein lieu des
pleins pourquoi parce que c'est trop
cher ici le gasoil est encore sous la
barre symbolique des 1 euro 50 1 euros
49 le seuil sera vite franchi dans
beaucoup de stations essence le sans
plomb est autour d'un euro 60 mais
atteint ici par exemple un euro 77 le
litre
le coût des carburants en hausse
rappelle à beaucoup le début des
mouvements des gilets jaunes en 2018
tout le monde devrait
se mettent ensemble et puis dire au
client n'ait recours c'est l'étape
diablement et axa serait très bien dans
la mesure du possible via la table il
faut être réaliste mais bon chose que
l'étape quand même une grande partie des
taxes et puis bon ça permettait de le
jouer les problèmes peut-être peut-être
des hydrocarbures mardi le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire avait expliqué
suivre l'évolution des prix et affirmé
que s'il en volley se poursuivent et il
faudrait je cite certainement réagir
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
il ya quelques jours la commission
indépendante sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église remettait son rapport un
rapport accablant faisant état de deux
cent seize mille victimes parmi elles un
habitant de la roche la molière dans la
loire georges magand qui a accepté de
sortir de son silence et de raconter son
histoire à céline ersilia de tl7 la
chaîne de la loire nous permettons donc
12 écrire car nous avons déjà eu des
contacts personnels et nous voulons
simplement vous dire notre proximité
notre disponibilité c'est sur moi je
crois en cette disponibilité le redis il
faut des actes et des actes de la part
d'un évêque un surtout georges magand
relie cette lettre signée par
monseigneur bataille il ya quelques
temps il avait pu s'entretenir avec lui
sur l'agression qu'il a subie par le
père peyrard dans les années 70 des
attouchements qu'il a subie alors qu'il
était en service militaire il avait
accompagné le père peyrard deux jours
pour l'aider à installer un camp pour
enfants le soir note id après midi le
terme latin tandis que l'as magenta
d'appeler la main grandi et le chalet
froid un peu ce que tu as ouvert plus
longtemps et il me dit viens avec moi
lance réchauffera qu'on pourra disputer
un petit peu donc on a discuté et puis
là ça s'est un petit peu emballé de de
son côté le les mains baladeuses et plus
que baladeuses
le pire est arrivé la parution de ce
rapport est une avancée pour georges
magand les chiffres et les statistiques
sont frappants il attend désormais des
actes de l'église mais aussi de la
justice qui juge trop clémente face à
son bourreau qu'est-ce qu'il a été
abandonné condamné à rien il y avait des
failles il est tellement admirée tout
pour mehtarlam est à la barre
c'est une personne qui répare qui repart
tranquille l'église prône en dix ans le
mourre de violence de dieu mort de dieu
d'accord mais l'amour des autres aussi
et comme patte d'oie donne une bonne
raison pour georges mag en l'église ne
peut plus se voiler la face le rouche
réclament aujourd'hui des lois et plus
de transparence de la part de l'église
voilà pour ces témoignages terribles
sans transition il y a dix ans était
lancé le réseau espérance banlieue un
réseau d'écoles adapté aux élèves en
décrochage scolaire ces établissements
aujourd'hui au nombre de 17 propose une
alternative à l'enseignement classique
et c'est ce qu'ont pu constater et
michael et me doro et nicolas landry de
tv 78 en se rendant au cours charles
péguy à sartrouville henri iv regardez
il est 16h15 c'est la fin des classes au
cours charles péguy de sartrouville
c'est l'heure des services ranger la
cour faire la vaisselle nettoyer les
vitres les 79 élèves de l'école sont
répartis dans des équipes internes
niveaux chacune sa tâche pour l'équipe
de stacy c'est le nettoyage des tables
et des chaises de l'école comme un
service eh bien il faut être toujours
ensemble et non à droite ou à gauche
créée en 2016 cette école fait partie du
réseau espérance banlieue elle compte
sept classes du cp à la 5e marie pierre
collet est enseignante depuis 30 ans
arrivé dans le réseau il ya quatre ans
elle enseigne aujourd'hui à une classe
de cm2 en rep j'avais 24 25 élèves c'est
comme si là je les avais tout le temps
en demi groupe donc on peut se permettre
quand même beaucoup plus de
manipulations en sciences notamment et
dans d'ailleurs dans toutes les autres
matière cet établissement destiné aux
élèves décrocheurs du primaire au
collège c'est la possibilité pour ces
jeunes de développer aussi un sentiment
d'appartenance des équipes aux noms de
personnalités historiques un uniforme
comme un tout c'est l'hymne national
entonné chaque lundi matin en levant le
drapeau national j'aime bien qu'il y ait
des uniformes et
j'aime bien aussi qu'on s'assemblent
lundi pour chanter l'hymne national
alors l'uniforme c'est un vêtement
effectivement que les enfants méritent
lorsqu'ils arrivent à l'école ils sont
civile entre guillemets et de par leur
attitude
en classe et à l'extérieur la classe ils
montrent qu'ils ont acquis et qui vous
mettent en pratique les cinq règles d'or
qui sont être joyeux penser aux autres
être propres et ordonnés être vrai et
bien travailler être curieux et ce soir
la cérémonie des avis a permis de
récompenser deux élèves nous avons pu
vous voir progresser de jour en jour
depuis le début que vous êtes ici est ce
que vous vous engagez par cette prise
donné forme à respecter les cinq règles
d'or est bien avec une grande joie je
vous le donne
avant de conclure la journée sur le
traditionnel cri de guerre du cours
charles péguy de sartrouville
[Applaudissements]
voilà et souvenons nous il ya un an
maintenant le 2 et 3 octobre 2020 la
tempête alex s'abattait sur la france un
bilan terrible dix morts huit disparus
et 217 millions de dommages un an après
la vallée de l'arroux ya une des plus
touchées par la catastrophe a rendu
hommage à ces victimes nous nous y
sommes rendus à un reportage signé de
yannick deux bus verts et de lionel
bernardo pour monaco info
c'était une matinée bien agitée dans le
paisible village de breil-sur-roya maire
préfet député président de région et le
prince souverain sont venus rendre
hommage aux victimes de la tempête alex
c'était il ya tout juste un an la
principauté avait alors grandement aidé
les habitants des vallées avec notamment
un don de 4 millions d'euros à
destination des sinistrés que ce soit la
mairie de monaco les associations les
entreprises la société civile monégasque
tout simplement qu'ils ont été
particulièrement mobilisé un autre côté
est à nos côtés les sapeurs pompiers de
monaco la croix rouge monégasque
on a eu vraiment une aide extraordinaire
telle qu'on aurait jamais pu l'imaginer
la journée a débuté par la messe
dominicale
damman comme les autres et puis c'est un
véritable cortège qui s'est dirigé vers
la maison du souvenir au monument
construit avec le bois arrachés par les
flots sous lequel une boîte aux lettres
a été installé l'objectif de cette
maison du souvenir c'est à la fois de
garder en mémoire ce qui nous ont
quittés les notamment les trois victimes
brioist de cette catastrophe mais aussi
la possibilité laissée aux habitants
dans cette boîte aux lettres de raconter
leur histoire et puis il ya eu
l'inauguration de cette plaque
commémorative sur laquelle les noms des
trois habitants briois décédé y figurent
le niveau de l'eau au plus fort de la
tempête est également gravé un marqueur
impressionnant situe à plus de deux
mètres de hauteur par rapport à la route
on a encore une trentaine de familles
qui ne peuvent toujours pas réintégré
leur habitation
des arbitrages doivent être rendus
certaines maisons vont être détruits
d'autres doivent être réhabilités et
puis nous avons toujours beaucoup de
chantiers pour la reconstruction des
routes qui doivent encore être rétablie
cette matinée lourde mais importante
s'est clôturée par le dépôt d'une gerbe
de fleurs dans le lit de la rouille à
celle qui a tant fait cauchemarder les
habitants de la vallée
voilà sans transition nous espérons pour
certains que c'est très bientôt que vous
irez dévaler les pentes enneigées en
attendant sachez tout de même qu'à
partir du 1er novembre les
automobilistes seront dans l'obligation
d'équiper leur véhicule dans les zones
montagneuses les explications en savoie
et haute-savoie de victoria lopez pour
notre chaîne partenaire sur place 8 mont
blanc
le 1er novembre la réglementation va
changer dans nos pays de savoie sur
toutes les routes de nos deux
départements les automobilistes devront
être équipés pour affronter l'hiver mais
de quel équipement par le la loi sur le
site du gouvernement on peut lire que
dans les zones établies par les préfets
les véhicules légers utilitaires et les
camping cars devront soit détenir dans
leurs coffres des chaînes à neige
métallique ou textiles permettant
d'équiper au moins deux roues motrices
soit être équipé de quatre pneus hiver
la loi concerne 48 départements situés
dans des massifs montagneux pour chacun
d'entre eux c'est au préfet d'établir la
liste des communes et des axes concernés
en savoie et en haute savoie tous les
axes routiers et toutes les communes
sont concernées sans exception du 1er
novembre 31 mars 2022 les garages sont
déjà pris d'assaut dans ce moment on est
sûr avec le 150 personnes qui appellent
par jour pour prendre des rendez vous
plus près une petite centaine de
personnes qui passent au moins pour se
renseigner des pneus adaptés c'est à
dire portant la mention 3p msf ou m plus
s des chaînes ou des chaussettes seront
donc nécessaires pour rouler sur les
axes savoyards et haut-savoyards cet
hiver mais la pédagogie et l'information
seront deux villes jusqu'en 2022 et les
manquements à l'obligation ne seront pas
encore sanctionné cet hiver pour ma part
non ça changera pas je trouve que c'est
un peu tôt parce que maintenant la
lignée de la neige arrive assez tard
quand même en pleine ya quand même
beaucoup moins de neige sur ces dix
dernières années donc je trouve ça un
peu tôt nouveau à moi mais
mais en soi de toute façon faut le
mettre parce que allez vous amuser avec
des pneus d'été sur neige on verra ce
que ça donne l'obligation d'être équipé
ne concernera pas seulement les
habitants de nos départements mais aussi
les visiteurs à commencer par les
nombreux voyageurs qui séjournent dans
nos stations pendant la saison d'hiver
voilà dans ce journal maintenant nous
partons pour l'occitanie pour une
initiative utile à cornebarrieu au nord
de toulouse la capitaine de police qui
s'appelle céline garde elle donne depuis
janvier des formations aux forces de
l'ordre et aussi aux agents de sécurité
volontaire pour lutter contre la
maltraitance animale une formation dont
elle détaille le programme au micro de
geoffrey priol pour vient occitanie sur
place nous avons tout ce qui est
l'intervention face à un chien en stress
ou dangereux nous avons ensuite toute la
réglementation des chiens de catégories
et ensuite tout ce qui est les atteintes
à la vie à l'intégrité de l'animal
d'authentiqués les infractions c'est à
dire le volet du contraventionnelle et
du délictuelle puisqu'il n'ya pas de
criminels endroit animalier après
l'occitanie nous partons pour la
nouvelle aquitaine elles sont sur toutes
les cartes postales je parle bien
évidemment des cabanes tchanquées du
bassin d'arcachon dont l'une d'elles a
été d'ailleurs construite il ya plus de
80 ans alors normal qu'elle ait droit
quelques petits travaux de rénovation
dominique parmentier de tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest s'est rendu pour nous
sur le chantier regarder
elle trône au milieu du bassin
d'arcachon comme deux soeurs jumelles
inséparables est indissociable du
paysage si la cabane numéro 53 celle aux
volets blancs a été entièrement
reconstruite à l'identique en 2007 la
numéro 3 ou volets rouges qui datent de
1945 menace de s'effondrer les 26 puis
en bois qui la soutiennent sont
totalement rongé par la mer c'est
pourquoi la ville de la teste a décidé
d'entreprendre en urgence des travaux de
consolidation menée par une entreprise
spécialisée
ils ont commencé le 29 septembre dernier
on travaille c'est de remplacer
et pieux mettant les plus beaux arts
dont deux par des plus better on
remplacera partie inférieure qui est
abîmer altérer et on vient chercher la
partie propre du bois en hauteur de
façon à pouvoir se raccorder un chantier
difficile au gré des marées on peut
travailler que sur le bassin maire de
façon à ce que l'eau soit pas un
obstacle aux travaux et après cette
semaine sur des grossistes et en
important on a un temps plus court à
travailler que ce que l'on avait ramené
la semaine dernière le chantier devrait
durer encore deux ou trois semaines coût
de l'opération 130000 euros une
consolidation temporaire en attendant sa
reconstruction inévitable car personne
ici n'envisage de voir disparaître ce
patrimoine identitaire mais dans ce site
classé natura 2000 soumis à de
nombreuses contraintes réglementaires
la procédure sera forcément longue va
falloir je dirais lancer des études est
monté
un projet on est en instruction donc en
respectant toutes les phases
administratives
mais ce sera un autre prix est de
l'ordre d'un million d'euros la ville de
la teste espère trouver des subventions
elle a même lancé un appel au mécénat
visiblement déjà avec succès
voilà nous partons pour la sarthe
maintenant je vous emmène au salon fait
lire au moment où étaient invités plantu
le célèbre caricaturiste lors girard de
lmtv sur place elle a tendu son micro et
voilà ce qu'il a dit au sujet de
l'évolution de son métier écoutez
d'abord moi ça me prend beaucoup de
choses sur la société qui change il ya
des questions qu'on me posait il ya dix
ans on ment pose d'autres aujourd'hui on
sent que la société a changé on sent que
maintenant est la liberté parler de la
liberté moi je ne posais pas la question
il ya vingt ans sur est ce que j'ai le
droit de dessiner jusqu'où je peux aller
je faisais mes descendants le journal
est donc faux tous les jours trouver des
idées et faire comme si
on n'avait rien fait depuis 20 ans et
des fois on peut faire un dessin qui
peut être mal compris mal interprété
manipuler et tout d'un coup on en prend
plein la figure
comme si on n'avait rien fait 10 ans 15
ans plus tôt et donc ça fait aussi
partie du boulot
voilà il est temps de le larguer les
amarres dans ce journal vous allez voir
ils sont lycéens et pendant près d'un an
ils parcourent le monde à bord d'un
somptueux voilier les veinards avant de
jeter l'ancré à porto au portugal il
était de passage à saint malo et bien
évidemment donc on sort de thé vert à
rennes capucine colin et agathe harel
ont voulu rencontrer ces lycéens pas
comme les autres regardez
ils viennent des quatre coins du monde
et ils ont embarqué pour une aventure de
dix mois à bord du seul land est un
voilier norvégien de 1927 pour cette
expérience chacun a dû débourser 60 de
1000 euros mais attention ici pas de
suites de luxe on vit comme des vrais
marins
vous voyez ces crochets ici c'est là
qu'on installe noah mac dans la cale du
bateau les 60 lycéens dorment mangent et
vont en cours car pas question de
laisser l'école de côté
et quand on est en classe on tire ce
rideau pour diviser la pièce comme ça on
a un groupe ici et un autre la cours de
maths d'histoire mais aussi de
navigation sur le cervelas net ce sont
les jeunes qui mène la barque pour leur
première escale depuis leur départ de
norvège ils ont jeté l'ancré dans la
cité corsaire
notre venue à saint malo est un heureux
hasard en 2019 nous naviguions vers une
autre destination
mais finalement ça n'a pas fonctionné
alors on a décidé d'accoster à saint
malo et ça a été une expérience
incroyable pour nos élèves après deux
ans de pandémie cette aventure maritime
s'est présenté comme une bouffée d'air
frais
c'était incroyable quand on a enfin
quitté la norvège tout le monde était
super heureux ont souhaité par tous sur
le pont et quand on a aperçu la france
en s'approchant des côtes quand on a
découvert les maisons et le paysage
c'était un sentiment dingue c'est
tellement différent de ce qu'on connaît
en norvège parce que chez nous il n'ya
que des petites maisons en bois et ici
il y a des magnifiques maisons en pierre
et en briques c'est super beau prochaine
destination
porto au portugal
retour en nouvelle aquitaine direction
limoges et son club de plongée sous
marine certes point de mer ni l'océan à
l'horizon mais ces amateurs s'exerce
d'abord en bassin avant de pouvoir aller
chatouiller les poissons et benjamin
delmas de 7 à limoges a pu assister un
de leurs entraînements regardé
par et pour le grand bleu chaque mardi
ces passionnés de plongée se réunissent
pour partager leur plaisir d'évoluer
sous l'eau
ont plongé à 4 mètres de profondeur dans
une eau à 28° alors d'accord ce n'est
pas la méditerranée mais les conditions
sont idéales pour ses plongeurs du club
subaquatique de limoges on démarre notre
nouvelle saison après une période un peu
compliquée et premier entraînement ce
soir en piscine ils ont choisi de
s'entraîner dans la piscine de vaublanc
un élément de sécurité pour acquérir des
réflexes souvent
c'est à dire qu'en mer on a tout de
suite les poissons
la motivation
la beauté est la raison pour laquelle on
est là c'est à dire le milieu marin
alors que en piscine on va acquérir des
réflexes alors l'idée bien sûr c'est un
club subaquatique c'est d'amener les
gens sous l'eau doit faire partager
découvrir ce qui se passe sur les fonds
sous-marins la beauté des fonds
sous-marins effectivement en piscine
puisque nous apprenons en piscine faut
bien commencer quelque part nous sommes
au centre de la france nous n'avons que
des lacs une fois que
les élèves en est qui le niveau 1 au
niveau 2 ans les niveaux en mer ou en
espagne à rosas on va en bretagne et
puis on va à l'étranger
mais avant de se jeter à l'eau il faut
connaître son matériel le csl assure les
formations des plongeurs du niveau à 4
il faut
[Musique]
pour que tu puisses après le mètre d'eau
sur la bouteille
c'est un peu comme si eux
on était un astronaute dans l'espace
sauf qu'on a revu ainsi propulsé quand
même mais
mais voilà c'est ça il ya cette
sensation de 3d on peut se mettre dans
la position qu'on veut on respire donc
ouais c'est ça reste une aventure
divisés en petits groupes appelés
palanquée ils sont encadrés par un
moniteur qui veillent sur leur confort
et leur sécurité les thèmes sont
disponibles tout au long de l'année sur
prise de rendez vous il n'ya plus qu'à
se jeter à l'eau
nous ouvrons une page musique mais aussi
amitié dans ce journal on connaît tous
la longévité de groupes de musique tels
que les rolling stones ou encore you
tout est bien dans l'aude un autre
groupe g 63 moins célèbre celui là mais
tout aussi talentueux a fêté ses 40 ans
d'existence alors le secret de cette
carrière hors norme c'est l'amitié d'une
bande d'amis d'enfance et puis la
passion des concerts qu'ils écument dans
la région
christophe rigaud est allé pour nous les
rencontrer lors de leur passage à paris
regardez ce reportage
40 ans de musique et 40 ans d'amitié
c'est une longévité rare dans le milieu
du rock mais ce ne sont pas les seuls
points communs de serge jean louis et
olivier tous membres du groupe g 63 ils
sont d'abord tous né en 1963 d'où le nom
du groupe mais ils viennent surtout d'un
petit village de l'aude clients d
origine qui ont construit l'âme du
groupe on est les audois on et off dans
cette année on le revendique haut et
fort parce que la musique n'est pas qu'à
paris et aujourd'hui quarante ans après
l'histoire continue
[Musique]
on écoute beaucoup la musique anglo
saxonne et queen comme sas games et
people et des épines ce qui va avec et
on est passionné de ça
avec un son résolument pop rock les
textes de g63 parc de notre quotidien
le chômage c'est pas de l'amour ça peut
être une faculté de quelqu'un que je
parle à auch en profiter le temps qui
passe et autres informations que nous
ayons une autre voie là et ça parle de
sucre mais le carburant du groupe ce
sont avant tout les concerts
face à leur public mais aussi en
assurant les premières parties
d'artistes reconnus ces particules ça
avec 15000 personnes on n'est pas trop
me tue à sion de choses mais on ya pris
goût par contre joueur répétition avec
les amis c'est très très bien c'est
super faire de la musique c'est génial
mais alors les concerts c'est
l'aboutissement de tout ça
et le plaisir mais alors à l'état pur de
passage à paris le groupe a fait un
petit détour par une salle mythique
l'olympia un rêve pour ces musiciens
mais pas une fin en soi quand on fait de
la musique à la première notion c'est la
notion de partage nous qu'on joue à l'om
cas aucun juste une charrette c'est
pareil pour nous c'est le partage mais
c'est vrai que ça serait l'aboutissement
est la récompense de beaucoup d'années
de complicité beaucoup donné travail et
ce serait génial de montrer que des gens
de l'ordre d'occitanie peuvent aussi un
jour avoir avant leur personnel piaf
après 40 ans d'existence et six albums
g63 ne compte pas s'arrêter là un
septième opus est en préparation avec un
seul mot d'ordre continuer à donner du
plaisir au public deux roues l'aude et
partout ailleurs
est maintenant de tendre images dans ce
journal
comme je vous le disais dans les titres
sainte lionceaux ont vu le jour au zoo
de plaisance-du-touch en haute garonne
ces charmantes boule de poils sont nés
cet été mais les visites ont dû attendre
ce mois d'octobre pour les découvrir
gambadant près de leurs parents
d'ailleurs de bien attendrissante images
signé agnès grimaldi pour la dépêche son
confrère sur place
on attend qu'il soit c'est assez
débrouillard assez assez agile pour ne
pas
ne pas rester coincé quelque part et
être qu'ils puissent à peu près se
débrouiller sans la mer là qu'ils
puissent la suivre au moins pour elle a
l'habitude à rentrer mais ils savent pas
encore comment rentrer comment les
nourrir et c'est donc pour être sûr
qu'ils suivent correctement la mer et
rentre bien le soir surtout on s'oriente
vers des détenus un peu plus fraîches
donc voilà on va être sûr que tout se
passe bien
voilà de bien tendres aux images de ces
lionceaux adorable maintenant âmes
sensibles s'abstenir éloignez vous de
vos écrans car dans la cité médiévale de
rodemack en moselle par la peine
d'attendre le soir d'halloween pour voir
des sorcières déambuler dans les rues et
cela même en plein jour le courageux
gens me l'ont de moselle tv leur a tendu
son micro écoutez les sorcières
pour le grand retour de la fête des
sorcières les visiteurs ont sorti leurs
plus beaux costumes mais alors à quoi
reconnaît-on une sorcière réussi je
pense que c'est très très maléfique donc
ça serait plutôt vers le noir avec des
chats noirs des animaux qui vont avec
tout ce qu'on connaît corbeau à assen
grenet
à ses beaux yeux
c'est libre cours à l'imaginaire donc
chacun et la sorcière qui est un qu'il
souhaite un concept qui visiblement
cartonne dans les rues étroites du
centre historique difficile de se frayer
un chemin le nombre maximum de visiteurs
attendus avoisine en et 5000 a largement
été dépassé on s'attendait effectivement
quand même pas à autant de monde et pour
le coup même en ayant prévu que
peut-être on s'y attendrait pas on s'y
attendait vraiment vraiment pas on
pensait pas du tout arrivé à saturation
les nombreux fans de pop culture et de
contes ou pratiquants d'arts occultes
ont pu se ravir tout au long de la
journée du marché des créateurs des
expositions d'artistes et des diverses
animations proposées un véritable voyage
dans un pays magique parfois maléfique
satisfaisant petits et grands
deux croix
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur tv5monde et sur vos chaînes de la
tnt on se retrouve pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous et bon courage
à toi
[Musique]